so my trade you tweeted that you said
you would reveal if you are team Ben or
team packs in in the final season so
there we are so million dollar question
what team are you on I am
so the end of never have I ever which is
so such a bummer for fans I think
because we've been along for this whole
ride but as actors like is it hard for
you guys to say goodbye to these
characters too oh yeah yeah I mean it's
so it's like Bittersweet I think that
for us like these characters mean so
much to us just personally not even
because we portrayed them for four years
and you get connected to a character but
for us like we really love them like
they're really like we're protective of
them I think like even their story lines
sometimes like if Ben would mess up I'd
be like oh yeah what are you doing yeah
um so it is hard to say goodbye but my
tree and I were talking last year and
the show I think we both said sort of
found us at the right time and taught us
so much and then I think it kind of knew
when we were ready and we got to tie it
up and the writers did such an amazing
job and now it's it's got a beautiful
bow on it it definitely was a satisfying
ending but now I'm curious that you say
that is it harder to say goodbye to the
experience then that's what I would say
we're finally seniors and honestly I
think we're doing pretty great now that
I've done this indeed I can focus on
what's important
I was gonna say actually for me
personally slightly different than like
more about Davey as a character but
rather it was hard to say goodbye to
waking up at 5am every day for my call
sheet you know and like I am not a
morning person but for my job I was I
was that person that was happy to wake
up happy to say hello to every single
person in the morning and like the crew
members most of which stayed with us
since the first season so most of which
saw me when I was 17 grow up to 20 years
old family yeah truly
like truly
like truly personally the most but in
terms of like even just the legacy of
Davey I'm not sad about that only
because I know that in the future only
more projects will come for many other
young actresses including myself where
there'll be more characters that are
just as amazing if not more I feel
really really grateful
I have this awesome life full of dope
people who care about me
and who loved me I'm excited about the
impact and personally as an actor I'm
excited for the unknown of like what's
next the future I love it so Darren when
you read the scripts or let's say
episode 10 what was your reaction to the
the ending hey
you were a really nice boyfriend but
honestly
you're an even better friend
do you also feel like there was a nice
bow to it
script number 10 was completely
different than what is in the show is
that right I don't think there is a way
to tie a bow on on a triangle like there
it's not good but it's just gonna look
and feel awkward so do you wrap a
pyramid present and put a bow on top a
triangle that's played out for Four
Seasons mind you too yeah I feel like
maybe maybe you put it on my face I
think I think it is Pyramid enough where
people want to see Davey happy that's
true you know yeah and I think she she
does end up happy and there's uh there
is a nice
nice Fade Out to the show so million
dollar question what team are you on I
am team Ben going are you excited are
you team Bud yeah well just the scream
of the team then I know a fellow team
that because I trust the writers this is
what they wrote you know like they're
not team bed I agree with you I love
that all all the love to the writers I
love that okay when the writers we trust
but no okay hear me out to you then
because okay remember when Paxton like
ditched Davey in season two yes I got it
he came back that's great yep I get it
but
um I know me if you're embarrassed to be
with me once you're embarrassed to be
with me like later because I'm gonna
only be more of a hot mess okay now Ben
is also a hot mess so it works it works
they obviously like yes as we know they
push each other academically all of that
but also like the banter I love banter
okay me too I'm a banter gal like in my
life if you don't have banter with me
you can't like roast me back and Ben can
keep up with her that yes you have to
keep up with me and I and I like seeing
that as an like a fan yeah I need to see
that banter I need to see them like you
know go off against each other and then
you get that
oh what I'm saying so I went out the
whole plant no anyway do it how does
that feel to hear that how do you feel
like Paxton How do you feel Darren and
to be fair enough no no no no how do you
feel Jared I feel great
oh man I'm just just disappointed you
know not for nothing though their
relationship was also impactful for each
other we saw it it was a time all good
things must come to an end yeah and it
led Davey to the right person
okay also not every relationship gets
closure and don't you feel like Paxton
and Davey got some closure they did
actually it was a nice little one wait
can we talk about the fact of like our
handshake yeah so I guess this is just a
student faculty professional
relationship now yep Vibes here are
officially over
that wasn't written in the script but we
did that basically season one when Davey
asked Paxton to have sex with her she's
like okay cool we'll Circle back about
it and then we decided when they decide
to like close their relationship it
would be Paxton extending his hand to
shake and like I hope fans caught that I
didn't catcher is so cute that's really
cute I love that yeah but I thought that
was cute now I have to ask because uh
you know Mcenroe at the end said dot dot
dot for now yeah so is this really the
end of never have I ever
think so yeah to our knowledge but I
mean hey Mcenroe knows all you know
something I don't know you never know
what Netflix is gonna do who knows
we definitely don't know how would you
feel about maybe a movie or a spin-off
of never have I ever if there was a
spin-off it would have to Star Trent
that's like yeah non-negotiable okay
sorry like it would have to Benjamin
Norris
the game for a movie a film I think it
would be cool maybe if we did it it's
gonna be funny some time from now okay
in like a 10 15 year kind of thing
depending on where we all are in our
careers I think that that would be more
so the way that we would do a movie if
we ever do one but who knows who knows
where we'll be